the action the emotion the grand world
it was all there I saw it as this great
female empowerment story an incredible
artist named Kushiro created bolita
battle angel 30 years ago Keshe Rose
creation is something that inspires
dreams
Elita battle angel is about a girl who
is plopped into the world not knowing
who she is solid and she goes on a
journey of self-discovery and discovers
that she's not an insignificant girl at
all
she is someone quite extraordinary dance
a little please
[Music]
it's all about this if you can make the
audience believe that that character is
real and a tight close-up and frankly
what are the only people that I trusted
to be able to do that I think we've been
able to create a seamless blend of
live-action and synthetic action in one
single frame she's just realer than real
if you asked me about the timing of
making Alita it's not the technology who
is finding Rosa Salazar Rosa cells are
fantastic I'm amore your honor I loved
her and I felt like her she was my
person to look up to it's amazing seeing
Rosa's spirit her light come through the
Alita character when you see something
like this it's like something that looks
so different than anything else we need
a movie like this right now
and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what they want you to think
[Applause]
you
you